earlier this week I did a story about
the stock market and specifically I
pointed out to you using data that
Donald Trump and Trump ist's have been
hanging their hats on Donald Trump's
stock market performance as a sign of
Trump winning and being good for the
country and that there are two major
problems with that number one is that
the stock market climbing is only good
for some people and when stocks go up
and wages stay the same that's part of
the problem that's how wealth continues
to accumulate at the top the bigger
problem though is that stocks rose more
under Barack Obama than under Donald
Trump I showed this graph when we did
the story the stocks went up nearly 59
percent during Barack Obama's first
three years in the S&P 500 only up 46%
during Donald Trump's first three years
stocks rising roughly 28% more during
Barack Obama's first three years than
during Donald Trump's first three years
now when I did the story I knew there
would be some trumpets who simply
wouldn't understand they simply wouldn't
understand the numbers but the degree to
which they're ignorant has been
weaponized into online trolling and
harassment and cognitive dissonance with
the goal of simply continuing to blindly
support Donald Trump it even stunned me
and I'm going to show you some of the
YouTube comments in response to that
story and the truth is I could do this
with a lot of stories that we do just
pick YouTube comments and show them to
you
the reason I'm choosing this one is that
the subject matter is so simple and it's
very objective it's not super open to
interpretation if you want to talk about
Donald Trump's a foreign policy
maneuvering what to one person seems
like a blunder could be some kind of 4d
chess to someone else and there's really
like a debate to be had about it this is
just super clear the S&P 500 climbed 59
percent during Obama's first three years
and 46 percent during Trump's that means
the S&P 500 the broadest of the big
three stock market indices climbed 25
roughly percent more under Obama than
under Trump it's cut and dry it's simple
check out these comments we have
examples of basically every type of
response
we imagined quote when you crash it
first it's easy to increase it lol this
is funny of course this is nonsense on
two fronts most importantly that stocks
didn't crash under Barack Obama that's
just made-up it's not true next comment
quote I mean a trillion dollar stimulus
package a government bailout of the auto
industry and near zero interest rates
will do that
the question is will there be
consequences and will you blame Trump
for them so this one is similar but it's
from someone with like a few more arrows
in their quiver saying that Obama
effectively bought himself an inflated
market with government spending that is
an admission that government stimulus
works first of all and hilariously they
seem to be saying that now that Trump
has no longer done the same thing as
Obama we are now seeing the consequences
which appear to be slightly slower stock
growth under Donald Trump completely
incoherent if it doesn't make sense to
you it's because it doesn't make sense
another comment yeah but a recovery
after a crash will rebound faster and
more easily I don't think that's
disputable again I specifically
mentioned this one yesterday it's a
fallacy
it's a post facto rationalization I knew
we would get this comment and we did
another comment quote the stock market
went up because of all that quantitative
easing money from the Fed and very low
interest rates under Obama
if Trump had quantitative easing and
near zero interest rates under his first
three years it would go up much higher
than what it has the stock market is not
a good indicator of a good economy this
one's funny for a few reasons it again
cites some of these normal Obama rigged
the stock market to go up with his
programs but then it also says Trump
hasn't gotten any Fed benefit even
though Trump has Trump's cotton rate
cuts he complained they weren't big
enough that's a whole farce but then
they also say the stock market doesn't
matter anyway in terms of evaluating the
economy yeah I said that yesterday and
yet still the metric that Trump and his
followers choose to use a stock market
performance
another comment quote wrong Trump had
multiple record high peaks higher than
any point during Obama you are being a
disingenuous Democrat also the market is
in the average person's benefit when
we have a market where companies are
struggling to find workers like now
versus workers struggling to find work
like under Obama this was just
incoherent and it's also laced with out
homonyms
so not a surprise and then lastly quote
what the hell have you been smoking the
market is up eleven thousand points
since Trump was elected and 401 K are up
from forty to seventy percent this one's
just a total non sequitur the market is
up eleven thousand points of which
market I assume they mean the Dow of
course we're talking about the S&P 500
and of course we're talking about the
percentage increase or decrease that's
what matters and whatever happened in
anyone's individual 401k is really not
relevant to the broader conversation
that we're having so the conclusion from
this we can't reason with these people
it's impossible I want to you to see
these comments to realize that even on
something this simple they can't be
reached you can't reason with them
you're not gonna convince that person to
say you know what you're right let me
vote for someone other than Trump in
November of 2020 they will not be part
of our removing Donald Trump they will
not be part of us accomplishing anything
if anything is going to be accomplished
so the the revelation needs to be and I
hope many of you have had it long ago we
need to go around them and just do
everything we can to prevent them from
interfering we're not going to convince
them to come to our side let's convince
people already on our side to get out
and vote in November of 2020 because
these people are not going to see the
light period